Do you have backyard chickens right now and have an abundance of eggs?
Here are five great recipes to help you use up those eggs.
First up, this is a nice simple one.
Poached eggs can be kind of hard to get the technique down,
but swirl, swirl,
swirl and you'll get there.
Next up is pancakes.
This is a great way to use up a few eggs and these can be customised.
Use chocolate chips,
blueberries, whatever floats your boat.
My kids love chocolate pancakes.
I like playing with maple syrup
and my baby loves the blueberry pancakes.
And you can't be a classic scrambled egg.
This can get rid of 10 to 12 eggs
and have some full bellies in the house.
Now, this one is one of my favourite.
This is French crepes.
I actually use a sourdough recipe for this.
It used eight eggs.
You can customize and finish crepes in any way you like.
Here we use chocolate sauce and some powdered sugar.
Now, if you're feeling a little extra,
you can make a Dutch baby pancake.
I love a Dutch baby.
This also can be finished in any way.
Here I'm using some raw whipped cream to top,
some powdered sugar and my favourite,
maple syrup.
Try out these recipes today and tell me which one is your favourite.
Mine has to be the Dutch baby.